On the next episode of AMC's The Walking Dead
Maggie said that her people could take care of The Saviors
So far, all they've done is put our community at risk
we need to talk
I'm not saving you any more
It's our way out
Why didn't you go with my dad?
I have to figure some things out
what is there to figure out?
how we can do this, if we can.
but we can't, no not like this
your dad thinks differently
and he's wrong
you know it
even if I think he is, I don't know
change your bandage later, be nice to Olivia
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie is a
new walking dead let's break it down.
Trevor from Grand Theft Auto totally back
so I can see Maggie doing just fine with the
doctor at hilltop next week Berryhill top-heavy
episode will pick back up with Jesus Gregory
their leader who is a nice juxtaposition from
Ezekiel you can see the Trevor in the saviors
rollup in a like look were changing the deal
you guys are all screwed.
Now in Gregory was totally ready to rollover
remember the hilltop community is relatively
small compared to the safe zone compared to
the kingdom.
So Gregory.
Unlike Ezekiel or even Rick even Rick after
Negan is a stronger personality and Gregory
is ready to completely do what ever Negan
the saviors want or really Trevor from Grand
Theft Auto because that's who is dealing with
here but a lot of what they're doing with
their setting up here is all comic book stuff
from March 2 war.
So without giving away spoilers like they're
just trying to tell you Gregory is probably
going to be a problem.
So the title of the episode the next deal
means a couple different things, to give the
saviors here trying to push their new deal
on hilltop and in the clip with michonne and
Carl they talk about Rick's new deal.
So the probably follow-up with Maggie.
I'm not expecting to see too much kingdom
stuff in the episode I think mostly with her
trying to imply is that the survivors are
going to try and work something out with hilltop
but at the same time the saviors will also
try to do that and douche bag Gregory will
somehow get in the way of all this.
And it'll be funny to see if Gregory tries
to perv out with Maggie again the last time
she was there.
He was kind of creep in and her but that's
also from the comics to like Gregory take
this weird fascination with Maggie what she's
getting her exam done but given was just happened
to Maggie will see how they treat her character
in this episode because the one she was basically
on the edge of death and she also went through
the trauma of losing Glenn Abraham and what
happened with the survivors.
So the main concern was in her losing the
baby but you can kind of see what they're
doing with her character like this is going
to be her hole to climb out of like they wouldn't
save heard then just to have Negan turn around
and kill her or kill her baby.
It can be like this big story of triumph at
least that seems like the direction they're
taking things we also see Sasha sharpening
her knife at hilltop she looks like she's
ready for business.
So really does see like were in the middle
of volume 19 march to war.
So if you want to read long in the comics
just read volume 19, March the war you make
sense of this is building towards volume 20
all out war should be like a really big action
set piece way to end the season or begin a
season will just see how close to the comics
they stick and how fast they speed along US
can let me know.
Do you think that they'll blow through marched
toward the first half of the season or anything
that will spill into the second half of the
season I think the been a little bit clearer
with the way they treated Maggie's character
in the art that they're setting up for her
and with Rick's character like he has a been
a quite as big a journey like you have that
episode one moment where he breaks in this
past episode episode for even seem like quite
as much of a coward.
As expected, but you look like it any moment
he might lash out at Negan see you can see
that eventually will just get the sum moment
where he can't stand it anymore and he will
want to go against Negan, but the whole idea
with that episode one moment were he's like
groveling on the ground just like completely
broken down is that Negan really did break
him Rick is not acting in something has to
shake him out of his funk and it didn't seem
like there was any clear moment where that
happened during episode four.
So there's still a couple more episodes before
the midseason finale may be will see that
happen sometime during that but you have to
remember that they do not have any guns like
even went as far is asked michonne if she
is also secretly hiding more weapon somewhere
so that he can get rid of them so there is
a huge corner to be turned before he starts
plotting against the saviors, but the funny
thing is that it seems like everybody else
is kind of doing it for him.
So when he finally gets that moment where
he says and up is enough, everybody else will
already be prepared the giveaway time will
say congratulations to this week's walking
dead giveaway winner Chase Morgan you win
a $20 Amazon gift card please private message
me on the back of my channel so I can get
your contact details and later today I will
be posting a Westworld video just explaining
all the theories catching people up on the
series.
They were confirmed for season 2 they already
got their pickup.
So there will be a 10 episode season 2 I'm
assuming it will air around the same time
next year as season 1 started like around
this time so I'll post that video in a couple
hours be sure to subscribe to get that it's
actually been a lot of fun but like walking
dead.
It also has to pay off some of the big things
that it set up and it hasn't done that quite
yet while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for last night's episode of
The Walking Dead and you can click here for
my game of thrones theory video.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five and I'll see you guys tonight